Speaker 1: Let's go next to Bobby from
Jersey. Bobby, welcome to the show.
Bobby from Jersey. Welcome. You're on the air.
Speaker 2:
Hello? David, could you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, now I can.
Speaker 2: I. Tremendous. So what do
you think about gun debate? Because it's
so messy of a topic to debate.
Speaker 1: What makes it messy? Well,
I think that it's it's really a cultural issue.
There are lots of people in the United States
who are either so enmeshed in gun culture. And
I will also say that there's people who are just
viscerally opposed to guns for cultural reasons,
that it's very difficult to get past it and to
think about it like we would any other kind
of empirical circumstance and say, okay, well,
what is the likelihood of a defensive use of
guns? And are we really curtailing the Second
Amendment if we have some restrictions and, you
know, all these different things now I know where
I come down on it. I don't really have I mean,
listen, I'm disgusted by what we might call
man. How do I say it? Like, oh, kind of like.
Speaker 2: Rural.
Speaker 1: Rural, right wing gun culture. I find
it completely disgusting. And I want nothing to do
with with the folks who are part of that. But
at the same time, it's not just for me about
the guns. I have lots of friends who are liberal
gun owners and they're responsible and they want
licensing and insurance and they're safe with
their guns and all these different things. So,
okay, we have a Second Amendment. You're not
doing anything wrong. You're not kind of like
a fetishist where you're fetishizing guns
and whatever, all these different things.
So I think because people are so ideologically
connected to the issue, it prevents us from
really speaking substantively. And I think if
we spoke substantively, we would we would come
down on we need way more regulations on guns.
Speaker 2: Yes, I completely agree. And I feel
it's a it's a it's pretty difficult to debate
emotion rather than like over empirical evidence.
Speaker 1: Well, that's going back to
the conversation earlier about abortion.
Imagine that we got an answer about when life
begins or when a fetus is a person that was
like scientifically definitive first. No. One, you
will never have actual everybody agreeing with it.
And even if we did, it wouldn't change
everyone's mind about abortion anyway.
So it's one of these things where the vast
majority of the debate, even if you resolve it,
won't actually resolve the broader issue.
Speaker 2: Yes. Yeah. I feel like too many
people have such a binaries. A binary view on
like a lot of a lot of issues. And I have. Sure.
That's something that really
annoys me. Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right. My pleasure.
Thank you so much for the call.
We're getting some solid calls today, guys. I have
to say, let's hope nobody, nobody ruins it. Now l